les combats linguistique le manitoba
connaît il faut rappeler qu'en 1979 une
simple contravention a poussé la cour
suprême du canada a invalidé près de
4500 texte de loi rédigée uniquement en
anglais cela a dégénéré à l'époque comme
une importante crise linguistique
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'ici les
services en français ne sont pas
protégés par une loi cadre mais plutôt
par une politique et quelques lois sans
grande envergure
longtemps le premier ministre grec c'est
le jeu lui-même bil'in a créé les packs
d'une loi cadre sur les services en
français sur l'opinion publique
anglophone
néanmoins et jusqu'aujourd'hui en 2015
les choses ont changé
le manitoba est une province bilingue
mais uniquement du point de vue
législatif
donc il n'y a pas d'obligation
constitutionnel de fournir des services
en français pour les quelques cinquante
mille personnes dans la province dont la
langue maternelle est le français
toutefois ce projet de loi pourrait
élargir ses définitions de francophones
à toute personne vivant ou travaillant
en france est donc techniquement ce
projet de loi pourrait faire doubler le
nombre de francophones dans la province
une victoire importante donc pour les
francophones mais une question demeure à
moins de cinq mois des prochaines
élections provinciales ici au manitoba
est-ce que ce projet de loi aura le
temps d'être adopté